foreign
can be a matter of life and death AI is
transforming the healthcare culture
completely patients doctors and Hospital
managers all have their lives made
easier by artificial intelligence which
completes activities that would
ordinarily be completed by humans in a
fraction of the time and at a fraction
of the expense hello everyone welcome to
Simply learn before moving forward
please make sure you subscribe to Simply
learns YouTube channel and press the
Bell icon to never miss any update from
Simply learn now let us see top 10
approaches of AI in healthcare
drug research and discovery
it takes a long time and money to get
from the research lab to the patient a
medicine must travel from a research lab
to a patient for an average of 12 Years
according to the California biomedical
research Association
artificial intelligence enable drug
development systems are existing
businesses in utilizing massive amounts
of data to swiftly identify patient
response makers and create more
effective and affordable appropriate
treatment option one of the more recent
applications of AI in healthcare is drug
Discovery the most recent AI
developments can be used to speed up the
drug Discovery and medication
repurposing processes according to a
study of the 5000 medication that start
pre-clinical testing and only one of
these five is ever licensed used in
humans additionally from the research
lab to the patient developing a new
treatment will run a cooperation of an
average of U.S 359 million dollars AI
helps pharmaceutical Industries in drug
design and also assist in deciding the
right product for the machine
next comes cancer diagnosis
AI is already being used to more
precisely and early diagnose diseases
like cancer the National Cancer
Institute claims that deep learning
machine learning and artificial
intelligence can all be utilized to
enhance cancer treatment and patient
outcomes
over 13 000 colorectal cancer photos
were collected by the researchers from 8
000 participants and 13 separate cancer
facilities in China Germany and United
States the researchers then created a
machine learning software using
photographs that technicians randomly
selected the software can identify
colorectal cancer photos which is one of
the leading causes of cancer-related
fatalities in both U.S and European
countries next important use of AI in
healthcare is in scanning and ultrasound
technology
a I can assist clinicians in taking more
comprehensive approach to disease
management better coordinate care plans
and help patients to better manage and
comply with their long-term treatment
programs in addition to helping
providers that is Health Providers
identify chronically ill individuals who
may be at risk of adverse episode
examining the metadata in a document
artificial intelligence May classify
metadata using more sophisticated
optical character recognition that is
OCR techniques this is the best
technology that has automated file
scanning document classification and
precise processing
AI ultrasound technology can be used in
CT scans for real-time analysis of the
data and image processing
ultimately AI will assist clinicians in
reducing their responsibility by
contributing in both CT or MRI scan
using different AI tools or robotics
treating neurological disorders
diseases associated with the peripheral
and central nervous system are known as
neurological disorder pattern
recognition uses a variety of ml
algorithms automatic classification
typically helps clinical decision making
on a brain pathology or many classes by
identifying patterns that matches to
different classes
thus solving neurological disorder for
instance we can say
classification based on anatomical data
are frequently used to identify
Alzheimer's disease and other forms of
cognitive impairment
robotics assisted surgeries it sounds
interesting for more than 30 years
medical robots have been in use they
range from basic laboratory robots to
extremely sophisticated surgical robots
that can work alongside a human surgeon
and Carry Out procedures on their own
robots have the potential to completely
transform Life Care by enabling patients
to maintain their independence for
longer and decreasing the need for
inpatient care and nursing facilities
they are used in hospitals and labs for
repetitive jobs Rehabilitation and
Physical Therapy and support for people
with long-term problems in addition to
surgeries
next is Healthcare assistance
virtual Health assistants are in charge
of a variety of tasks such as answering
protein patients call and emails and
keeping their medical information while
protecting sensitive data setting up
doctor appointments reminding patients
of follow-up visits and clinical
meetings Etc
terms using cognitive computing
and augment reality and body and voice
movements are combined to generate this
cognitive Computing and augment reality
helps to stimulate and solve complex
human thoughts so both patients and
medical professionals gain from the
decrease in hospital visits due to use
of cognitive Computing and augmented
reality and other AI Technologies
diagnose blood related diseases
when it comes to early diagnosis of
potentially blood Related Disorders
artificial intelligence is a huge asset
doctors are now able to check for
Dangerous compounds and germs in blood
samples such as staphylococcus E coli
Etc at a far faster rate than any other
manual scanning for the machines to
learn how to locate the dangerous
bacteria researchers examine for more
than 25 000 pictures of blood samples
using AI robots with 95 percent accuracy
this will significantly lower the
fatality rate
next comes managing customer records
in the healthcare sector gathering and
analyzing data such as past experiences
and medical records typically present in
this phase data Administration may be
greatly streamlined by integrating
artificial intelligence and digital
automation robots are being employed to
gather reform it store and Trace data to
make information access quicker and more
reliable reputable iot solution
companies have been working closely with
hospitals and other Healthcare
organization to develop tools that
combine strong AI a number of healthcare
companies have turned to AI as a result
of data science in healthcare to stop
the loss of data they can now segment
and connect the necessary data using
artificial intelligence which used to
take years to handle
next is fraudis detection and security
while many customers look for cost
effective Medical Care the number of
fraud cases is also rising at an
exponential rate most medical
institutions and patients have sustained
significant harm as a result of this
AI helps to safeguard a vast amount of
data produced by the healthcare industry
by detecting Elements which are out of
place
so artificial intelligence using process
navigation is helped to reduce fraud in
hospitals and other Healthcare
Industries these fraud attempts have
significantly decreased thanks to AI
based resolution since they enable
complex process navigation and fraud
detection
and top 10 use of AI in healthcare is
kovid 19. we all have gone through this
phase and we all know how difficult was
that phase of covid-19 and you might
have seen how a artificial intelligence
has reduced this problem
by quickly analyzing massive amounts of
research data AI Technologies and
methodologies can Aid in the
understanding of kobit 19 virus and
speed up research on remedies
AR text and data mining techniques can
find out about the virus origin spread
and diagnosis as well as on management
strategies and Lessons Learned From the
other pandemic AI can also be used to
track down the infection diagnose it and
stop it from spreading the spread of
covid-19 is already being detected and
predicted by algorithms that recognize
patterns and image recognition systems
are accelerating medical diagnosis for
instance early warnings can be provided
by AI powered early warning systems by
mining popular news internet content and
other information channels in several
languages this can augment syndromic
surveillance and other Healthcare
Networks
I hope you enjoyed watching this video
thank you for watching happy learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here